in this video I want to talk about the
regulation of glycogen metabolism so we
talked about glycogen synthase and
glycogen phosphorylase has both being
enzymes involved either making or
breaking down glycogen which brings me
to my points here so glycogen
phosphorylase breaks down glycogen we
talked about how that makes glucose
1-phosphate which can be converted into
glucose 6-phosphate which can go onto
glycolysis like a gin synthase on the
other hand makes or synthesizes of
glycogen doesn't break it down it adds
glucose adds a glucose unit to a vicodin
chain so now these two enzymes do
opposite things right and because of
that we would never want both of them to
be active at same time at the same time
so we never want both active at the same
time we don't want to make luke glycogen
and break like a gin at the same time
that would make no sense would be
counterproductive so we want one to be
active while the others inactive okay so
glycogen phosphorylase it breaks down
glycogen frees up glucose which goes to
glycolysis so that so that we can make
energy so when would this be active when
would we want to make energy well this
would be active during low energy states
right this would be active when we want
to make energy so when we have low
energy we want to make energy right and
it would be inactive during high energy
states if we already have energy there's
no sense in making more so glycogen
synthase would actually be the opposite
right when we want to make glycogen when
we want to store glucose right this is
when we have plenty of glucose when we
have too much energy so this would be
active during high energy states and it
would be inactive during low energy
states
so essentially glycogen phosphorylase is
involved in making energy whereas
glycogen synthase is involved in storing
energy okay so now these are both
regulated
they're regulated allosteric Lee and
covalently as code as far as covalent
modification both of them now the
covalent modification is actually
controlled by hormones I'll get to the
allosteric regulation in just a moment
so which hormones control this there's
insulin and there's also GU GU gone and
epinephrine and I don't want to talk too
much about these I just want to give you
just enough information to help you
understand how these things regulate
these enzymes that we're talking about
so insulin its function is to lower
blood glucose levels okay you're
probably familiar with insulin being
evolved involved with individuals who
are diabetic they have high blood
glucose levels insulin is meant to lower
blood glucose levels we'll talk more
about that actually later in the in
future videos so insulin function is to
lower blood glucose levels so it
responds to high blood glucose levels
okay it responds to high blood glucose
levels and says okay I need to lower
them so its function is to lower blood
glucose levels glucagon and epinephrine
okay the way I kind of remember glucagon
glucagon I think oh no glucose is gone
so make more right so it's actually
involved in increasing blood glucose
levels so it actually responds to low
blood glucose levels so when blood
glucose levels are low we want to
increase them epinephrine you might
already know it as the fight or flight
hormone so when you're in danger right
epinephrine is active and epinephrine
actually also functions functions like
glucagon in that it increases blood
glucose levels because you need energy
when you need to fight or fly so you're
going to need to increase the blood
glucose level so that you can break it
down for energy so what would these
hormones here how would they play a role
in activating the phosphorylase or
deactivating the phosphorylase or
activating or deactivating the synthase
well we just mentioned up here that the
phosphorylase is involved
making energy right it breaks down
glycogen to make more glucose right so
so insulin insulin what would it
activate if it's job is to lower the
blood glucose levels well how which one
of these enzymes lowers blood glucose
levels
well blanketing synthase takes glucose
and stores it as glycogen where as
phosphorylase takes glycogen and frees
up glucose so block Allegiant
phosphorylase increases glucose levels
whereas glycogen synthase decreases
glucose levels so which which hormones
work with that so then insulin would
activate the the enzyme that decreases
blood glucose levels so it's going to
activate like a-- gin synthase whereas
glucagon and epinephrine want to
increase blood glucose they will
activate like agent phosphorylase and at
the same time they were each each
hormone right will deactivate the other
one right so if this will deactivate the
phosphorylase right it'll deactivate the
thing that increases blood glucose
levels and glucagon will deactivate the
synthase right especially since if one
is on you want to make sure that the
other is off so let's sort of do a
diagram for this specifically glycogen
phosphorylase so glycogen phosphorylase
is the enzyme that increases blood
glucose levels or just glucose levels in
general I don't even need to write this
blood portion here let me just cross
that out but even though that made a
case may be the case anyway if we
imagine this this enzyme here is
packaging phosphorylase actually all of
these are where we're going to go into
detail what's going on here so this here
is glycogen phosphorylase and this is
mikage and phosphorylate specifically in
its t form it's T State and we remember
that the T State was the inactive form
of the enzyme okay now what would happen
if we added an enzyme called
phosphorylase kinase what would that
thing do well it's a kinase so it's
going to add foster
to something what is it going to add
phosphates to and where these phosphates
coming from since it's a kinase its
attaching phosphates from ATP okay so
that's the grimming go from ATP to adp
now it's adding these phosphates from
from ATP to phosphorylase so it's adding
them to glycogen phosphorylase in this
case we're actually adding to ATP and
we're going to get out to adp so that we
have a phosphate group here in a
phosphate group here so now this is a
form of covalent modification here this
is a form of covalent modification we're
making these bonds to - to these
phosphate groups to create an art form
an active the active form of the enzyme
so now this here is now basically the a
a like permanently active when it
permanently excuse me it's it's a
covalently modified active form so this
thing is going to be active no matter
what okay
so what would trigger or what would
stimulate phosphorylase kinase what
would covalently activate this well
which hormone is involved in this well
these are the ones that are going to be
the ones that increase blood glucose
levels so this is going to be stimulated
by glucagon and epinephrine okay so
is one way to activate glycogen
phosphorylase now when as long as it has
these phosphates on it it's pretty much
going to be active okay now if we want
to go ahead and deactivate that then
we'll add a phosphoprotein phosphatase
so this is a protein that has phosphates
on it and we're going to phosphatase it
all right we're going to hydrolyze some
phosphate groups off so we're gonna add
some waters and we're actually going to
get you're actually gonna add two waters
and get two phosphate groups off two to
go back into this inactive tea form so
which end which hormone would stimulate
stimulate this enzymes activity well the
one that would make make glycogen
phosphorylase inactive right which would
be the insulin so now this here that
I've just talked about this is all
covalent modification and how that
regulates so this is everything I just
talked about in this sort of area here
was covalent modification and how
covalent modification can regulate this
enzymes activity
now what about allosteric regulation so
now so this this inactive t form here
can be allosteric lis regulated to
become active so that's this here this
is this going here going on over here so
here we can go from the t's form to the
art form right which is active if if
what happens right when with a
phosphorylase be active well one of the
allosteric regulators is high levels of
a MP so high levels of a MP would
allosteric lis regulate this t form and
activate it because this is an indicator
of low energy indicates low energy so if
this indicates low energy glycogen
phosphorylase is increasing the blood
glucose concentration so that we can go
to glycolysis so we want that to happen
when we have a low energy so high levels
of A&P indicates that we've used up a
bunch of ATP so that would be an
allosteric activator
of glycogen phosphorylase okay so this
thing is an activator there are two
inhibitors that I'm going to mention
those two inhibitors are are things that
indicate high energy right so that would
be things like ATP and/or g6p these are
both allosteric inhibitors right they're
going to favor the T form so these both
indicate ATP indicates high energy right
that indicates high energy whereas the
g6p indicates that we have plenty of
glucose around okay indicates a high
amount of glucose already so there's no
sense in freeing up more glucose if we
already have plenty around so we'll
inactivate the the phosphorylase so what
do we have over here so this here is
allosteric formula all these vertical
arrows describe allosteric regulating
these horizontal arrows describe
allosteric regulation so here what we
have here now there's actually one more
thing that I want to mention briefly and
that's that when we have when we have
once the phosphate groups here are
attached this thing is active so here
this is actually a slightly more active
form it's still an hour our former it's
still active but it's a little bit more
active a little bit more active than
this one up here and the reason why is
because if there's a high level there's
a high amount of glucose around if
there's a glucose around then that will
actually if there's a lot of glucose
around that's going to allosteric ly
inhibit this this this enzyme a little
bit more so this is not like to too
crazy but on the whole idea is that is
that if there's a bunch of glucose
around it's going to be a little bit
less active but if there's no glucose
around then you'll prefer this more
active form right to be to be making
more glucose okay so that's that's this
is specifically glycogen phosphorylase
and we also there's also glycogen
synthase so glycogen synthase I'm not
actually going to draw up the whole
crazy diagram for it but I just want to
talk about it really quickly so it had
the opposite effects of phosphorylation
which which I
wanted to mention really briefly before
I go on is that notice here we
phosphorylated right the inactive
phosphorylase right to make it active so
phosphorylating this protein got it into
the our phone which was active now
synthase glycogen synthase when it's
phosphorylated it's actually inactive so
glucagon and epinephrine they stimulate
the phosphorylation of both the
phosphorylase and the synthase so
phosphorylation of the phosphorylase as
we just saw above it activated it right
but phosphorylation of the synthase that
inactivates the synthase so in both in
this case what ends up happening is that
well we have the phosphorylase active in
the synthase inactive so what are we
doing we're breaking down glycogen to
increase the blood glucose levels which
makes sense because that's what both of
these hormones are supposed to do now
insulin stimulates the dephosphorylation
of both enzymes so when the
phosphorylase which we just talked about
just up there when it's d phosphorylated
when this phosphorylase is d
phosphorylated it's in this t form it's
inactive form whereas the
dephosphorylation oops
the dephosphorylation of the synthase
actually activates it so in this case
right we have the synthase active and
the phosphorylase inactive so what
happens glycogen is formed to decrease
blood glucose levels which is which
makes sense because insulin is supposed
to decrease blood glucose levels as far
as allosteric control of glycogen
synthase goes at a high amount of g6p
will activate the dephosphorylation of
the synthase so so d phosphorylation is
synthase which activates this in base so
even when there's no insulin around
right - actually - actually you know do
this covalent modification here there
there is this allosteric control that
can that can you know get glycogen
synthase to do it is to do so I wrote
here in purple that you could try
drawing a model similar to the one above
but do it for glycogen synthase so if
you're interested in wanted to sort of
test your knowledge go ahead and do that
do a little diagram sort of like this
but instead of doing it for buckles and
for
trifer glycogen synthase given given
this information down here I hope that
video is helpful thanks for watching